oh vladimir gutierrez last time he faced
the pirates location of his pitches
where not exactly where he wanted him to
be look for him to shore that up
goes to the breaking ball in the dirt
put out complete
[Applause]
here's the pitch to sutsugo he ropes one
to right toward that shallow porch and
that's out of here a line drive home run
for yoshi sutsugo
out to right and he hits number eight
the pirates lead one to nothing you know
and man it's something else this guy you
know there were questions about him
catching up the velocity
well he got a first pitch fastball and
now that he'd catch up with it he
pounded it so one nothing the pirates
have an early lead
brian reynolds it's a high fly ball to
right back goes castillanos and clear
the deck with another
cannonball an anchor down brian reynolds
number 24 back to back jack
it's two nothing yeah that
wasn't that much deeper than yoshi's
with the
how high it was you know that's out in
any ballpark it doesn't matter where
gutierrez gets gamble looking the ending
begins and ends with case but big flies
in between and tonight it's going to be
the left-hander dylan peters going for
the box yep he's done such a nice job
and down on strikes
change up well that is such a great
pitch
ground ball to short farmer scoops it up
the peg in time to first and that's an
out
and he strikes out park three k's for
gutierrez a rebound second three up
three down
here's the pitch swinging a miss huge
rip struck him out on a low and away
curveball
and he goes down swinging that's three
strikeouts for dylan peters those aren't
changeups
curveballs he's striking guys out on
just like that don't worry about
power numbers or anything else get a
quick swing off and he does
another hit for him
see the ball hit the ball
here is yoshitsugos
wow a base hit into right center field
this will score peters
tucker will go to third and yoshi
tsutsugo
see the ball smoke the ball
and it's three nothing
here's brian reynolds he homer to right
is last time up
and now reynolds with a fly ball tucker
has great speed he'll score easily
tsutsugo retreats and went back to tag
but it's
another run sac fly for reynolds and
four nothing pirates
pirates with four hard hard-hit singles
in the inning roller
and they will not double up newman just
a little extra time farmer took to get
that ball to india as all newman needed
to beat the throw he gets the rbi and
the pirates take a five-nothing lead
to left center
down the first reds base hit india slams
on the brakes at second
reynolds recovered well
two on two out a two out walk and a two
out single will bring nick castiano's to
the plate
he bashes one to straight center
reynolds sprinting back
off the wall
india scores farmer speeds around third
he scores a standing double within an
eyelash of a homer
castellanos has the reds on the board
it's 5-2
the left-hander on the mound and a
left-handed hitting bottle at
i think any time joey goes deep up a
lefty i think he enjoys it a little bit
more
man oh man
his 32nd of the year his fifth off of
southpaw he leads the team with 91 rbis
[Music]
right back to left center goes to
shields this won't be caught all the way
to the wall to shields
shuts it down at second the base is
standing double
his third double is a red i saw that
ball come out of his hand now i'm ready
to hit yeah
there's a lot of truth to that
[Music]
oh there's a little pop-up that's
trouble come on use your speed
yes the speed
he outruns
jonathan indians pop-up
joey botto to the plate who went deep
last time up
deep right
he's tied to the game
watch out bono's hot again
the fourth multi-home run game this year
for joey battle the 17th of his stellar
career that's homer's in three straight
at bats bravado
now suarez at the game all even at five
[Music]
suarez cranks it deep left center
[Applause]
the reds lead
yeah i'd say this reds team feeds off of
the joey vados show a little bit
yeah but to see geno have some success
look at those guys i think everyone is
feeling
so happy for him it's been such a
struggle well just the batting average
wise
27th homer
for gino suarez
bouncing ball diving stop hoy park and
throws to first what a play
he brian hayes like from hoy park
tremendous
clothesline over to first base here too
look at it right on the chalk line bang
[Music]
guards the line here against kyle farmer
[Music]
farmer well head deep left field gone
the home run barrage continues for the
red legs that is a hanging breaking ball
you hang it we bang it nice job farm
[Music]
castillanos
back to back multi hit showings
and he works a walk
aboard for the fourth time tonight
and here he walks to load the bases
for delino de shields seven unanswered
by the reds poised for more bases loaded
two outs enter enyel de los santos
runners go
and a missed down a bases loaded walk
eight five reds
nick castiano's two-run double single he
has scored twice
castillanos to right india had gotten a
break he rounds third suzugo from right
throws in no shot india crosses standing
insurance from castellanos
[Applause]
reds win it 9-5
well it certainly did not start off too
well you can see that second comeback
win from five runs
this season
vladimir gutierrez didn't quite have it
but let's give credit to the bullpen
gave this offense a chance to come back
and come back they did
you